joining us now a long time remember the
minnesota vikings defense heart and soul
of that unit he's eric kendricks eric
welcome back how are you pal
good how are you doing great great to
see you great to talk to you you know
that defense
this year i mean we get spoiled because
it's been so dominant and we saw the
difference
when you weren't available as you get a
chance to reflect
on the year where is that defense right
now
and and where do you think it needs to
go from here
um you know it's got to be better you
know um
first and foremost but uh for the most
part you know
we start a new season next and this next
year and that's how i feel you know i'm
restarting
um obviously in the offseason right now
but yeah you know we every every team is
going to be different you know teams are
going to have coaches that leave
teams are going to have new new people
on the staff we're going to have rookies
you know we're going to have rookies
that are now that's
their second year so um you know
with that being said you know it's
always going to be a new field it's
always going to be a new
learning experience so i'm open to it
i'm excited and it was such a strange
season we were talking to
justin jefferson earlier today about
playing home games
with no one there did you ever adjust to
that reality of going out into that
beautiful stadium that has such a great
home field advantage for the vikings
and there's no one there yeah you know
justin never got to experience that you
know um
but you know hopefully soon but uh yeah
you know i never really got used to it
you know we did get used to it we didn't
get used to playing
but it's just there's something missing
you know what i mean and uh you can't
you can't ignore it
um especially you know when we're home
it's clear advantage like you said
uh for the defense he had that
experience at lsu without a hundred
thousand people there generating the
noise and he said it it just
was difficult to develop energy and he
thinks that's one of the reasons why
the team had a slow start one and five
just couldn't get it going
for the home games did you share that
same same belief that it took a while to
get the team going this year because of
that
adjustment that you had to make oh
definitely you know um
energy is a is a big thing you know
especially on the sideline
and uh you have guys like justin
jefferson who are self-starters you know
you don't you know
some people need a lot of you know fan
energy some people need a lot of their
teammates energy
things like that but um it was important
to find that that
that energy within yourself at the
beginning of every game
and um show with justin for sure you
know the flip side of it too though
despite the rough start there was an
impressive stretch where the vikings
willed their way back into playoff
contention
what do you think the catalyst for that
was um just how we worked every day you
know we we
weren't we weren't um obviously winning
at the beginning of the season but um
our hard work day in and day out
definitely you know it didn't go
unnoticed and that stretch of wins
because
everybody was trying to do the right
things you know everybody was showing up
on time everybody was working hard and
um everybody was
holding each other accountable in a
sense too but uh you know it
wasn't wasn't working for us but um we
started getting that stretch of wins
and it felt good how's your coach mike
zimmer evolved over the years that
you've played for him
um just just from when i started playing
you know we've had we had different
personnel on defense especially
and um offense has changed throughout
the course of uh
you know the league every year so you
know we just had to make little
adjustments as far as
our defense and things like that concern
um but we just have to do them fast we
have to learn
week by week because each team is
bringing a new challenge
yeah one of the challenges for the
vikings new offensive coordinators
all the time for whatever reason it was
kevin stefanski leaving to become coach
of the browns
now it's gary kubiak retiring i
you know that does does that put
pressure on the defense when the offense
is
kind of like yeah i don't want to say in
flux but it feels like that's the
the situation when you get a new
coordinator four in four years
it's got to feel like the offense is in
flux um i just feel like the defense
should always feel a little pressure you
know what i mean
like obviously offense is one thing we
can i can't worry about that you know i
got to do my thing on defense and um
we got to stop these officers from
scoring points and and they're doing it
in major ways you know especially uh
you know with with uh high powered
offenses like green bay in our league
you know we gotta
we gotta buckle down and and keep those
points low
i mentioned justin jefferson earlier
what was your impression of him on the
field in practice
uh he's a dog he's a straight baller um
yeah you know like i said he's
self-starter he came in and he he knew
what he wanted to do
and he went out and did it and he you
know he had that confidence he had that
swagger um
and he obviously worked for it young
receiver young
secondary as well how have you seen the
defensive back specifically the corners
grow this season man it's a lot of it's
a lot of learning you know it's a lot of
uh communication and it's just the
little the little nuances the little
details you learn
from just getting snaps under your belt
that uh
that propelled you to the next level
it's a huge difference too not having to
neil hunter he was developing into one
of the best pass rushers in the nfl
had that that neck injury that just was
kind of there and then the next thing
you know he's shut down for the season
have you been in touch with him and is
he
good to go for this year um definitely
been in touch with him i'm i'm not going
to speak on his behalf of what what's
his health condition but
yeah you know just talking about him and
his mental health and he's doing well
and um yeah you know i was talking to
the other day actually
this vikings team has settled into a
cycle where it's playoffs one year no
playoffs the next year playoffs
no playoffs how do you break that cycle
man
i don't know we gotta we gotta just work
i mean i only know one thing to do
really
and like you said you know it it has
been a little bit up and down since i've
been there
and um you gotta be gotta be more
consistent for sure
justin said that he was surprised that
the buccaneers went into green bay and
beat the packers to earn the spot in the
super bowl were you surprised that the
bucks got it done at lambeau field
um you know it was a hard game but i
feel like they beat up earlier in the
season you know sometimes people just
got
the other person's number um anybody can
weigh in any day this league you know it
comes down to
really a few plays when you look at the
film always you know explosives or
turnovers things like that so um am i
surprised
you know no you know did i think that
was gonna happen you know no
yeah you guys didn't see patrick mahomes
last year he was injured during the game
at arrowhead stadium it was matt moore
instead but
what's just the talk among your your
teammates when they see what mahomes can
do
and he just seems so different than any
other quarterback in the nfl right now
i mean he just keeps his eyes downfield
and then he just he just shuffles around
so effortlessly it's kind of annoying to
watch as a defender
honestly but uh it's cool at the same
time you know um
he's definitely he's definitely um
balling
your quarterback kirk cousins has been
there three years now year four is
coming up
where do you think he stands by way of
getting enough credit does he get enough
credit is he criticized too much what's
your read on
how outsiders view him man everybody
loves the hater man
i just i i felt like that since since he
got here you know
since he's been in league really but um
you know he played well for us
this past year and he's a leader on our
team shows up every day
a good guy who are the leaders right now
on the defensive side of the ball
obviously you're one of them who else
provides that voice to get everyone
going
man we got uh we got anthony harris we
got
harrison smith we got the new i mean we
had a couple injuries but i would
normally say to neil hunter
and anthony barr um and some of those
guys you know they don't really lead by
you know vocally
so to speak but you know their actions
and their intentions and
and just the way they carry themselves
around the locker room you know it's
just it's contagious
and it builds a builds a culture eric
i'm going to admit in advance i can't
recall whether or not you played in the
buccaneers game were you were you
available for that one i was not yeah i
didn't think so but but you were around
for the preparation i mean what's the
focal point of a defense
as it's getting ready to deal with tom
brady and the weapons he has at his
disposal um just know where they're
lined up at
you know um no no know what number of
receivers which you know
they got they got mike evans you know at
inside receiver you know at three you
know
it might be going to him you know like
it's just just things like that
obviously the run game is going to be
pretty simple
downhill um get the ball in the hands be
physical run game
um but yeah you know just just know no
other weapons are on the field and no
you know
splits three by one two by two things
like that and
you'll be all right you became the
vikings walter payton nfl man of the
year nominee for good reason you were
front and center with
efforts by the players to get the nfl
to to make advances when it comes to
social justice what what progress did
you see throughout the course of the
year and what would you like to see
the league do moving forward man just
keep keep
everyone uh keep banding together to you
know create this positive change you
know um
there's just so much we we still need to
learn um collectively as well as
individually
and just keep that quest the pandemics
seem to throw everything off too how
strange was it this year and did you get
used to
going into the team facility and all the
measures all and it worked it paid off
the nfl ultimately didn't miss a game
but was it was it harder to do your job
with all the things that
you needed to do in the facility while
traveling just the different
and and the many disruptions to your
routine um it was definitely
definitely adjustments you know we had
to be made um mental physical
um just protocol that you had to go
through
you know obviously but at the end of the
day i i think looking back at it you
know i was just
i really felt blessed that i was able to
go out there and play football and um
and and be safe doing it eric i
mentioned that cycle earlier
under that cycle this is a playoff year
so i hope
the cycle holds for this year and then
you break it
after 2021 and you get to the playoffs
two straight years that's the year to
break it not this year
you're not getting to the playoffs you
want to you want to break it next year
and get to the playoffs two straight
years
no there's no future in the past and i
gotta just move move forward
well we wish you all the best
congratulations on being nominated for
the
walter payton nfl man of the year award
and we appreciate everything you've done
to make your teammates coaches and
everyone in the nfl
sensitive to the challenges of social
justice and we wish you all the best in
the future eric
appreciate it take care hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports